[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy rabbi Howard Jaffe of Temple
Isaiah in Lexington Massachusetts
recently illustrated how futile and
self-defeating efforts said interfaith
dialogue are all too often when he
invited the Foxes into his henhouse he
staged an event entitled out of many one
featuring the demos n of the Council on
american-islamic relations care Stefanie
Mars ook of the Muslim Muslim justice
league and Jael and Samir nasara Dean of
this Islamic Society of Boston cultural
center is BCC now care of course is
hardly a trustworthy partner for
dialogue it was named an unindicted
co-conspirator in a Hamas terror funding
case care officials have repeatedly
refused to denounce Hamas and Hizballah
as terrorist groups several former care
officials have been convicted of various
crimes related to Jihad terror cares
co-founder and longtime board chairman
Omar Ahmed as well as its chief
spokesman Ibrahim Hooper have made
Islamic supremacists statements about
how Islamic law should be imposed in the
u.s. ahmed denies this but the original
reporter stands by her story care
chapters repeatedly infrequently
distribute pamphlets telling Muslims not
to cooperate with law enforcement Kerr
has opposed virtually every anti-terror
measure that has ever been proposed or
implemented and has been declared a
terror organization by the United Arab
Emirates a care operative recently
called for the overthrow of the US
government
rabbi Jaffe not surprisingly did not
inform his congregation about any of
that that his out of many one event not
only that but he allowed two of the
speakers to call for donations to care
and other Muslim organizations go out
and donate to any Muslim organization is
BCC care Jetpack muslim justice league
come on donate to us said ma zen from
care who added my project this year is i
have to raise a million dollars don't
send clothes send money i'm not afraid
to say it anymore nor were the muslim
speakers
afraid actively to mislead their
audience Marzuki defended tarik mahana a
former member of the is bcc who plotted
a jihad massacre in the united states
for al-qaeda mah Zhen claimed of course
zero percent of Muslims are doing
violence in the Greater Boston area I
would argue that zero percent of Muslims
are doing violence in America at large
apparently he's forgotten about two
other former members of the is BCC
Tamerlan and Dzhokhar tsarnaev who set
off bombs at the Boston Marathon in 2013
for Allah and Islam as well as about
Syed Rizwan Farook and tashfeen Malik
the San Bernardino jihad murderers Nidal
Malik Hasan the Fort Hood Jihad murderer
say follow Sai paav who murdered eight
people in New York City for the Islamic
state and so many other jihad terrorists
in America at large Maz n was not
through deceiving the audience however
he also said that it turns out that care
isn't Muslim Brotherhood I mean the
Muslim Brotherhood doesn't really exist
in this country there's no political
Islam in reality most major Muslim
organizations in the US including care
have extensive links to the Brotherhood
instead of all this deception a genuine
and worthwhile interfaith dialogue event
would have featured Jaffe asking Maz n
Marzuki and nasara Dean what they were
doing to come back among Muslims the
literal understanding of the
anti-semitic texts in the Quran the
Quran depicts the Jews as inveterately
evil and bent on destroying the
well-being of the Muslims they are the
strongest of all people and enmity
toward the Muslims they fabricate things
and falsely ascribe them to Allah they
claim that Allah is power is limited
they love to listen to lies they disobey
Allah and never observe his commands
they are disputing and quarreling hiding
the truth and misleading people
staging rebellion against the prophets
and rejecting their guidance being
hypocritical giving preference to their
own interests over the teachings of
Muhammad wishing evil for people and
trying to mislead them feeling pain when
others are happier fortunate being
arrogant about there being a laws
beloved people devouring people's wealth
by subterfuge slandering the true
religion and being cursed by Allah
killing the prophets being merciless and
heartless never keeping their promises
or fulfilling their word being
unrestrained in committing sins being
cowardly miserly transformed into Apes
and pigs for breaking the Sabbath and
more they are under a laws curse and
Muslims should wage war against them and
subjugate them under Islamic ajumma knee
but had he been aware of all those
Quranic texts at all rabbi Jaffe would
not have dared upset the general feeling
of goodwill by bringing them up and yet
they're still very right there in the
Quran and Muslims are still acting upon
them aided by the naive fatuity of
non-muslims such as Kerr's rabbi Howard
Jaffe the out of many one event
represents a moral myopia of
catastrophic proportions
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]